[Música]
bienvenidos a este enlace andino desde
ecuador en esta emisión hablaremos de
las movilizaciones indígenas que
mantuvieron paralizado al país por más
de dos semanas explicaremos las demandas
que estaban entre las exigencias de las
organizaciones y el gobierno ecuatoriano
conoceremos cuál es el peso histórico de
las protestas sociales un país donde más
de un millón de ecuatorianos son
indígenas además de las consecuencias y
preocupaciones que ocasionó el paro
nacional en este país y para terminar
comentaremos cómo terminó el conflicto
para un gobierno que apenas cuenta con
su primer año de gestión
[Música]
como la jornada de movilización indígena
sacudió por más de dos semanas ecuador
estos grupos protestaban contra el
presidente conservador guillermo lazo
porque no les ha dado respuesta a las
diez peticiones de tipo económico y
social que exigen desde hace más de un
año
miles de indígenas llegaron protestando
las calles de la capital ecuatoriana con
una larga lista de solicitudes vencidas
que el gobierno no había podido cumplir
entre las exigencias estaban congelar el
precio del diesel a un dólar con 50 y la
gasolina económica en dos dólares con
diez además demandaba una moratoria de
un año de créditos vencidos del sistema
financiero para que las familias
indígenas paguen sus deudas acumuladas
por el quiebre económico originado por
la pandemia del cobre 19
asimismo exigían precios justos en los
productos del campo y detener la minería
en sus territorios o en fuentes de agua
entre otros reclamos
los temas más sensibles como el
combustible el problema financiero el
alto costo de la vida los precios de los
productos de sustentación de los
campesinos el problema minero de ahí
hemos visto también que gracias de esta
lucha hay algunos parcialmente hay
algunos temas como es el tema de la
condonación de la deuda hasta tres mil
dólares créditos para los productores en
subsidios hasta 50 por ciento de la urea
pero ahí no queda si no hay otros temas
también que esto tiene que ser valorada
y hemos venido como indígenas reclamando
nuestros derechos por el alto costo de
la vida que realmente sufrimos
en nuestras comunidades a todo el pueblo
ecuatoriano la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de ecuador es
un movimiento social con articulación
política su capacidad de convocatoria es
su principal fortaleza han protestado
contra cualquier política neoliberal y
por la defensa de sus territorios frente
la exportación minera y petrolera ha
sido así durante hace más de 30 años los
movimientos indígenas son catalizadores
sociales del ambiente político y social
en ecuador han sido protagonistas en la
destitución de varios mandatarios
ecuatorianos en gran 1997 del ex
presidente abdalá bucarám en enero del
2000 del ex presidente jamil mahuad y en
2005 el ex presidente lucio gutiérrez
antes de esta nueva protesta de 2022
donde también rechazaban acuerdos del
gobierno ecuatoriano con el fondo
monetario internacional ya se habían
levantado en octubre de 2019 contra del
alza del combustible en el gobierno del
ex presidente lenin moreno tiene mucha
legitimidad tiene enorme capacidad de
movilización porque tiene la estructura
territorial más grande que pueda existir
en el país hay más de 5000
organizaciones comunitarias adscritas a
la conaie son literalmente millones de
personas que forman parte de este
entramado social y en consecuencia son
un sujeto político el movimiento
indígena produce el 80 por ciento de los
productos del campo que se consumen en
la ciudad las movilizaciones y bloqueos
de vías pusieron en riesgo la seguridad
alimentaria del país andino que llevaron
al incremento de precios
desabastecimiento de los productos y
servicios básicos mientras los indígenas
reclamaban derechos del resto de la
población se preocupaba por las
consecuencias del conflicto social
existe un sector de los ecuatorianos que
se opone a las manifestaciones de calle
y a la violencia según un estudio de
opinión de la encuestadora cedatos un 76
por ciento de los ecuatorianos
consideraba que las paralizaciones deben
terminar que nosotros estamos aquí es
justamente para a luchar por la paz para
pedir por nuestros hijos de que haya un
entendimiento entre el gobierno y la
clase indígena la escasez de alimentos
es otra consecuencia de las
movilizaciones indígenas agustín pas
niños vende frutas y legumbres reclaman
no poder reabastecerse a causa de los
bloqueos de vías por parte de los
indígenas estamos desabastecidos
por lo que no llega al producto de la
sierra nos llega la fruta de la tierra
nos llega lo que llega a llegar a
superar
todo eso nos afecta pues a mí como
conversar tener recta bastante la
solución definitiva parece haber llegado
de una mesa de negociación con mediación
de la conferencia episcopal se logró un
pacto para poner fin al paro nacional se
acordó a intensificar y fortalecer los
controles de precios en sus provincias
para evitar la especulación también una
declaratoria emergencia en el sector
salud la implementación de las políticas
sociales ofrecidas y la reducción en 15
centavos de dólar el precio de la
gasolina extra y del diesel
según registró el gobierno ecuatoriano
hasta el momento 500 millones de dólares
son las pérdidas arrojadas por causa de
las movilizaciones indígenas en menos de
un mes hasta aquí esta edición en la
sede andino desde el ecuador os invito a
seguir con la programación de france 24
en españoles gracias por acompañarnos
hasta la próxima